we are gathered here today to pay our
respects to Lisa and her family
and to share our memories console one
another to the degree that we're able
and though under such difficult
heartbreaking and somber circumstances
also to celebrate the life of a friend
a loved one
a beautiful and good soul and a
cherished and deeply missed family
member
Lisa is loved and missed by many and
will continue to be loved and missed by
all those whose lives she touched do you
need some time on your own
do you need some time
[Music]
hello
my take
[Music]
she's been pushing for a while
can we cut this one slack and let her
lie down
and today we talk about Lisa Marie we
look at Priscilla as a mother as a
mother to Lisa Marie we look to Lisa
Marie and say you lost a son
mothers losing children
it there are no words for it
so today we talk about action and action
is the way we can go forward we can
light the flame
so for Riley for Harper and Finley and
for the entire family
we March forward in support of you all
of us are with you
you
make me
real yeah
you make me
[Music]
strong as I feel
you
love me
[Music]